tous les bateaux tous les oiseaux tous
les soleils harriman toutes les roses
toutes les choses qui s'émerveillent
l'enlisement petite fille ma rue
j'accueille michel et agnès b
tous les oiseaux tous les soleils toutes
les rouges toutes les choses qui fait
merveille
tous les bateaux tous les oiseaux s'est
extrait d'un cd intitulé je te donnerai
ou fait des duos michel leeb avec
mathilde seigner sur les divorcées avec
evelyne bouix sur est maintenant avec
caroline cellier sur les vieux amants et
christina reali sur la belle vie voilà
il ya aussi un duo avec marc lavoine et
gérard darmon sur une chanson qu'on
adore qui s'appelle alors raconte voilà
on a eu l'idée de faire ça avec avec six
femmes voilà dont une que je connais
depuis 2007 fannie là oui je connais les
musiciens et chanteuses sa soeur elsa
elle c'est plutôt la comédie il a été
remarqué par lellouche
tom votre fils 14 ans il a joué avec
vous dans madame doubtfire et ça va ça
avait pas mal et je vais pouvoir
m'arrêter de travailler bien qu'ils font
lanceur alors on a regardé le pk c'est
ce que c'est le pk électronique press
kit voilà qui contrairement au clip
n'est pas exigée par orlando qui sent
donc yeux et son foie relandeau il dit
le p caïman fu c'est pas obligé donc qui
n'exige pas le pk vous en faites ce que
vous devez faire quand même c'est
regarder votre caméra tous les deux là
et dire magnéto serge attention les
enfants
magnéto serge